Hello大家好，欢迎来到这期怀露写真机，我是海鲁。
我是静雅。
那么今天这期节目呢，我们想和大家聊一个我们构思了已久的话题。
嗯，然后也是一直以来很想和大家聊的有关于摄影的分类吧。
嗯，那就是风土摄影。
对，然后这个风土摄影可能大家第一次听说啊。
这个词好像是我们首创的。
就是我们线编的朋友们。
所以那个接下来我们给大家讲一下什么是风土摄影。
就是我们是如何给这个风土摄影定义的。
以及为什么我们觉得风土摄影值得大家去关注一下。
嗯，对，那让我们来先拆解一下风土这个词啊。
因为风土这个词在中文里其实历史已经非常悠久了。
是。
就从先前时期应该很多古籍里就已经出现了这种用法。
嗯，然后那么它到现在为止呢，意义上也没有太大的变化，
都是只带一个地区的这个自然气候，
然后加上这个客观的地贸啊，
然后这些地理环境或者你理解成是一个客观世界的这个地方的地形，
或者说它的这个城市构造这些加上它的这个气候变化呀，
加上可能有的时候这个自立会带有一点点历史的感觉。
对对对，它有历史的纵深感，
因为只有时间才能够养出某一种气候对吧，
它才能形成某种土壤结构啊等等。
就总之风土这个词吧，
它的涵盖的这个意思最初还是比较指向在这个地理对地理方向上。
嗯，然后渐渐的呢，
到现代大家可能很少单独把风土拉出来用了，
更多的时候大家习惯会用风土人情来形容，
因为可能会觉得单独指风土的时候呢，
这个东西过于客观了。
但是当我们想只带某一个远方的世界某一个城市的时候呢，
加上人情能把它的人文活动也涵盖进去。
而且我觉得就是说这个人情的部分其实它也是超越于自面意思的。
就比如说我认为风土人情中的人情它其实包含的是这个地方的。
人们共同的集体记忆或者说是他们因为这片土地所形成的共同的一种人类智慧。
嗯，但是在我们日常口语中啊，
可能大家会更多的把它理解成一个巨像化的结晶。
就比如说当我们谈到风土人情这个词的使用的时候，
你会想到的是某个特定的第七的节日，
然后或者是一个地方特产，
或者是一个名圣古迹的景点等等的。
然后但是我们今天给大家讲为什么没有用风土人情摄影而是用风土摄影呢？
就是因为我们觉得可能更重要的还是回归朴素一点的这个感觉，
更抽象一点，它并不是我仅对自然进行描述，
也不是说我对一些凝结好的非物质文化遗产进行描述，
而是说它人和自然共存的时候或者说长久以来生活在这片土地上的人，
无论你是生活了几年几十年还是上百年和这个地方一起和自然环境条件一起。
形成了一些难以直接表述的庞大的有这个精神文明的集合。
是的，所以我觉得风土真的是汉字中我特别喜欢的那种词汇。
就是它又简单，但是它又包罗了很多很多的东西进去。
就是它包含了很多概念，它是一个很综合的感觉。
而且是那种非常意识形态层面的，但是它又没有脱离现实。
就是它可以包含意识形态在里面，
然后你想这个词本身它又是两个可见和不可见物质的融合，或者是组合。
是，刚才海鲁说先请的时候就有这个词，
但是至今我们还在用，包括不仅中国人在用，
日本人也非常喜欢使用风土这个词，
他们也有这个概念。
主要是在20世纪初1930年的时候，日本有一个哲学家叫做和氏哲狼。
那么和氏哲狼是在读了黑格尔的这个时间与存在之后，
然后他想加入一些自己的理解，他觉得就是现代人的这些性格，
因为那个时候刚刚开始全球化，
然后所以他就提出的风土理论是一个地方的这个自然环境，
会塑造这里人的一种精神状态，一种民族性，
就比如他说日本人，日本人同时兼具这个忍耐和爆发的特征，
因为日本是一个常年受寄风影响，
所以他们会很温顺，可以忍耐这个事情，
因为他总会觉得这个事情是轮回的会有一天变好，
所以他会更温顺一点，比就是海洋境气候来说。
然后爆发是随这个富士山是吧？
对，就是因为这个岛国的灾难实在是比较多。
总是憋着股劲。
对，台风，地震，然后洪水这些，
所以对于日本人来说，他们又很会追求这种爆发式的力量。
总之就是他会去这么理解，比如他说像中国这样的一个广貌的寄风地区，
然后他又相对比较稳定，
整个人都会性格会比较能隐忍，然后温顺。
对，他可以接受勤劳这种感觉，
然后当然比如到欧洲那边的话，
可能更多的是游牧习惯多的国家，
那就会有更多的这种比如民主与自由的这个想法在里面，
因为他更多的需要一些规划之类的，
当然这是他的一种想法。
但总之从那个时候开始，
就是日本人在观看风土这个词的时候，
就更多的会把人和自然的关系是如何互相影响的这个意义，
去融合到这个词里面。
就感觉他也更测重于人了，
在这种概念之下你也更能追溯自己，
去探索自我的一种感觉。
对，他比传统中文里的这个风土可能更多的有向内的感觉，
引导人去思考人和环境的关系，
或者说人和环境共生的模式的这个意思在里面。
好，那讲完了风土，
我们就来说说风土摄影。
对，就是为什么风土这个词其实非常的古老，
也不新鲜，
那为什么风土摄影作为一个新的分类，
它可以被我们提出来，
甚至可以让大家去更多的关注一下。
我觉得首先就是，
我们刚才也讲了就是说风土这个词，
其实你看它包含了很多的东西在里面，
它既可以包容空间，
地方可能科丽度大到一个城市，
一个国家，
然后小到一个行政的区域，
或者说是一个社区，
一条街道，
对,
然后它只要是聚集了一群人，
然后他们是有这个共同的记忆，
然后有这个地方又有独特的，
比如说气候，
或者自然，
或者说是民俗的话，
都可以拥有自己的风土。
那它在画面上，
其实就可以展现出很多。
风土摄影可以包含之前很多，
已经使用了很多年的这个经典分类里面的画面，
就比如说风光摄影，
其实它很多时候拍摄的，
如果你聚焦在一个地区，
那也是风土的展现和代表。
对,
然后如果你想记录一些这个地方里的人，
那它可能会涉及到笑相摄影。
对,
然后如果你去接拍，
其实有时候你记录下的是一个比较经典，
或者说比较能让人联想，
有代表性的一个场景，
那也可以算在风土摄影里。
对,
但是我们觉得这个风土摄影，
它不是简单的对于过去的一些概念的集合，
对,
它是超越了很多过往的一些摄影的这种概念，
或者理念的。
对,
我觉得最重要的点是在于，
它有一个由外部的世界走向精神世界的这么一个过程，
对,
或者起码它要同时并重这两侧。
嗯,
而且就是我们觉得这个风土摄影，
因为它，
你想,
风土嘛，
它要有时间的厚度，
嗯,
它要有人，
所以它不是一种决定性瞬间的这种拍摄，
嗯,
对,
它可能一张照片你是难以感受到风土的，
而且这一张照片的拍法也可能比较，
比较特别一点，
嗯,
当这个人在没有防备的情况下被你拍到的时候，
其实信息量是比较少的，
嗯,
更多的是摄影师挑选光线与构图，
然后去用自己的一个经验，
赋予给这个画面的信息多一点，
对,
它有一个此时此经此刻，
向地之手的那种感觉，
对,
然后,
但是我们所分类的这种风土摄影呢，
它是一种你在观看这张照片之后，
它会自然的引导你进入到那个世界，
进入到那里生活的人的精神世界，
让你看到那个景色，
是,
我觉得我们讲了半天，
然后还挺虚的，
嗯,
我们接下来就进入到这个，
案例部分吧，
我们给大家举一些例子，
嗯,
就是过往的一些摄影师，
或者和他们的作品那些，
我们觉得是有点，
可以花分在风土摄影里面的，
嗯,
然后,
我们刚才准备的时候，
一个比较景，
然后离大家比较近，
然后知名的摄影师作品，
是来自埃利克索斯的这个，
呃,
免于密西西比，
是的,
嗯,
首先,
大家看它的这个项目，
还是被一个明确的这个，
这个地点，
所框定了，
就是密西西比河，
是的,
它是有明确的一个自然，
或者说空间上的限制的，
对,
但是它在拍摄的时候呢，
看画面，
它没有用什么，
呃,
宽画副，
然后去拍一条河的样子，
啊,
或者拍河岸这种行为，
对,
或者拍了密西西比，
嗯,
很多景点，
它更多的是，
把镜头拍在，
在那生活的人，
是,
而且它也是一种，
类似于摆拍的东西，
它会让这个人把自己，
呃,
生活中积累，
对,
或者说，
它的爱好性格，
梦想,
展现在这个画面里，
对,
而且它也会拍一些，
没有人的，
嗯,
这种不片嘛，
然后比如说，
一个沙发，
没有人坐在那，
但是当你看到这个沙发的时候，
你看到这个物体的时候，
你想到的还是人，
你会想，
它的主人是什么样子的，
嗯,
或者当你看到这个人的时候，
你会想，
它生活的街区，
是什么样，
它是什么职业的，
嗯,
所以我觉得，
风土摄影它，
会有这种，
物与人之间的，
流动的，
这种感觉，
画面中的物，
和人都会引导，
你去想到，
在这个地区的生活，
对,
这个地区，
本身的一些特色，
对,
然后,
它的信息量也是，
多于这个画面，
本身所给你的，
嗯,
对,
就比如说，
它很经典的那张，
拿着飞机，
然后站在自己家门口的那个，
男人,
对,
那它其实是一个，
怎么说呢，
我觉得大家看完之后，
都不会，
简单把它理解成一个，
喜欢飞机的男人，
这么一个形象，
嗯,
它有和它是密西西比，
对,
这个地方，
然后包括，
它站在一片雪地，
嗯,
对,
你又会想到，
那个地方的气候啊，
嗯,
还有它的特性啊，
对,
然后它还有一本影集嘛，
是那个，
尼亚加拉，
嗯,
对,
然后它这本影集，
虽然它围绕的一个主题，
是Love,
爱这个主题，
但是它其实也是，
基于,
尼亚加拉这个地方，
所展开的，
嗯,
尼亚加拉，
本身是当地一个，
很,
著名的，
蜜月旅游，
或者说是，
这种,
情旅旅游出行的景点，
这个,
蜜月情旅，
打卡,
就是,
尼亚加拉的一个风土，
嗯,
对,
尼亚加拉，
这个地方，
就是,
处处,
可能你都能感受到，
这种,
浪漫的氛围，
嗯,
对,
然后它就拍摄了，
很多情旅，
嗯,
像,
觉得,
很像诗集，
嗯,
因为,
它能让你想到很多，
嗯,
然后你看到的画面，
也不是说，
那么的统一，
嗯,
比如说，
不像,
类型学呀，
什么的，
对,
它不是把人拉到一个白墙前头，
然后拍很多张，
嗯,
一样构图，
但只是人不太一样的，
那种画面，
嗯,
它更多的还是，
你随着每一次，
这个,
长境的变换，
你还是有在，
这个,
但是,
人的丰富程度，
和人与人之间的共性的，
又让你去，
联想到当地的，
这种精神为名建设的样子，
如果以日本摄影来举例的话，
其实,
我觉得三人大道的，
新宿系列，
还是比较合适的，
嗯,
对,
也是有一个地点嘛，
嗯,
对,
因为新宿本身，
代表着日本战后，
历史的一个，
它就是一个，
很典型的地点，
是,
然后在那生活的人，
在那条街上，
出现的生活方式，
其实都是，
从日本战后的精神，
和物质一起发展，
所得来的，
对,
然后三人大道，
又一直生活在那个地区，
嗯,
所以,
它在新宿街头拍的东西，
其实,
我是会把它看成是，
新宿的风土摄影，
是,
很多标志性的画面，
你到现在还都能找到，
对,
就是它的那个画风，
就已经可以代表新宿了嘛，
嗯,
对,
它的潮流感，
对吧,
然后包括，
高对比黑白所产生的，
对一个混乱世界的，
这种,
反思,
不信任感，
不安定感，
然后包括，
就是,
它这个画风，
最早源于这个黑暗舞台，
其实,
这也是新宿，
地方文明，
很重要的一个元素，
是,
嗯,
我觉得，
按照我们的那个，
定义啊，
像,
这个督主想依的，
Tokyo Style,。
其实它也是一个，
风土摄影，
嗯,
不过它的这个，
颗粒度可能更小一点，
嗯,
它展现的是，
就是,
东京,
当时的一个，
比较新的，
生物方式，
对,
就是,
这个城市，
当时的一种，
情深状态吧，
是,
年轻人都住在，
不大的房子里，
然后,
过着,
非常,
摩登的生活，
嗯,
然后他们可能，
就是,
看上去，
没有那么的，
传统式的，
一种阔出，
但是,
它依然，
有一种，
东京的一个状态嘛，
对,
因为你现在，
再去看，
东京人的生活状态，
还是那个，
还是那个样子，
或者不如那个时候，
嗯,
对,
他们会买什么东西，
它的,
它的家，
是怎么布置的呀，
可能都很小，
但是里面，
挤满了各种，
衣服啊，
文化产品啊，
贴满了很多海报啊，
等等啊，
嗯,
我觉得它还是，
很能代表，
东京的这个风土的，
因为东京，
就是这样的一个都市，
它的理念，
就是这个样子，
应该也是有不少的，
风土摄影的，
因为上海，
其实,
在整个中国的摄影室中，
嗯,
和这个城市，
这个地方相关的影像，
也是非常多的嘛，
嗯,
对,
然后就比如陆元敏，
就是很多这个，
上海摄影师，
和上海人都喜欢的，
嗯,
因为,
就是拍上海的摄影师，
其实,
他的作品里，
有很多的画面，
和很多，
那个时候也拍上海的，
比如外国摄影师，
不一样的是，
是,
他喜欢的那种，
上海的生活氛围，
很浓重，
是,
你们一下能够感觉到，
他是,
在这个地方，
生活了很久，
嗯,
对,
就比如说那个时候，
在上海接拍的话，
其实是一个，
比较常见的行为，
嗯,
因为那个时候，
有很多的这个，
外国记者，
他可以去上海，
但是他们拍下来的时候呢，
他会不自觉的，
去拍下那种，
上海,
和他们熟悉的文化，
差异最大的那个瞬间，
嗯,
他可能还是会被，
上的场景，
去刺激到，
嗯,
就有一种外宾视角嘛，
对,
但是陆元宁，
选择去拍的那个元素呢，
是,
作为上海人，
才能盖得到的一些东西，
嗯,
就比如说，
他如果去人家家里，
拍照的时候，
他可能会，
拍一个，
穿着旗袍的女人，
住在画面中央，
对对对，
然后周边都是，
没有加以那么多致敬，
但是可能，
都是那个年代，
很常见的生活用品，
而且这个，
穿着旗袍的这个女士，
就非常能够代表上海了，
她的穿着，
对吧,
然后她的面容，
嗯,
那个状态，
就是反正我一看，
我就能够感觉到，
我这,
一定就是上海女人，
嗯,
然后还有一类，
就是给我，
印象特别深的元素，
就是,
陆元宁会捕捉那种，
呃，人偶，
嗯,
就是女性人偶，
然后,
但是他摆出了一个，
非常就是优雅的动作，
啊,
他对于这种人偶啊，
或者广告牌上的这个人形啊，
就是,
是经常会去拍一下，
带到画面，
这个应该也是当时，
上海的一种流行元素，
然后,
这也是很上海的感觉，
就是上海就是一个，
很女性化一点的城市，
嗯,
然后他会有那种，
跟大胆一点，
对,
跟时尚，
潮流,
嗯,
对,
然后,
所以就比如说，
这些元素，
给我的刺激，
会让我觉得到现在为止，
如果生活在上海的人看到了，
他并不是，
是基于一种，
对那个年代的怀念，
而觉得这张照片熟悉，
对,
而是说，
他通过元素引发的，
你对上海的那个氛围的，
感受,
嗯,
是为了现在你在上海的感受，
有很多接近的地方的，
是,
因为,
共同的那个作用点，
是上海这么一个，
起码近几十年，
他一直保持同样性格的，
这么一个城市，
像他的那个摄影机，
苏州河，
其实也是很多，
都是围绕这个，
苏州河畔的人，
和他们的生活，
所拍摄的嘛，
然后像苏州河，
其实他连接了，
上海,
和无松江，
苏州那边嘛，
嗯,
是他现在，
是流到了，
经济湖那边，
嗯,对,
他的很多画面里面，
也会有那种，
江南水箱的，
场景,
然后你就会，
能够感觉到，
江浙湖那一带，
就是有，
水,
而,
构建起的连接，
嗯,
像这张，
有一个台阶，
然后走上那个，
桥嘛,
嗯,
然后我们每次，
那个苏州河那边，
都会走这个桥，
都要上那个台阶，
往上走，
我看这个图的时候，
我就特别有感触，
我觉得，
哇塞,
这个桥，
竟然有这么长的历史了，
然后他这个画面中，
有三个女人，
在,
往桥上走，
就是有一种，
他作为摄影师，
影面走来，
三个女人的这个视角，
然后他们也都，
穿着非常的时尚，
一看就是，
精心打扮的样子，
穿着高跟鞋，
然后,
在弹效风声的感觉，
我觉得，
就和现在的，
上海女生，
她的生活是一样的，
只是可能，
那个船，
稍微老旧一点，
嗯,对,
就其实，
嗯,
在风土这件事上，
要有那种，
差异感是很重要的，
就比如说，
我们说，
从桥上跳下去，
这个事情，
发生在上海，
它一定是，
露一瓶，
跳下去了，
然后,
但是如果发生在天津，
那就是一个大海，
也跳下去了，
对吧,
这个事情，
一定会有很多这样的，
你如果不严谨一点说，
可能是刻板印象，
嗯,
但是,
之所以会有刻板印象，
是因为这个规则，
会很强烈的，
在这边，
土地上，
不断的重复，
不断的强化，
你对它的记忆，
对,
然后,
露颜敏，
所拍的上海，
还有一张我特别喜欢，
就是,
嗯,
她的这个画面，
是左右的，
这样的一个布局，
然后,
左边是几个，
女孩子，
是几个，
淘气的，
小男孩，
然后,
他们坐在一个，
特幽塔的车子上，
然后,
你一下又能感觉到，
确实啊，
上海就是一个，
经济很发达，
然后,
有很多，
进口车，
可能,
嗯,
上海人是最早，
开上,
很好的车的，
这样的一个城市的，
嗯,
对,
就是,
她会,
其实重要的不是特幽塔，
而是进口车的那个概念嘛，
对,
而且又是，
很多小孩子嘛，
这城市也是，
非常,
着急蓬勃的感觉，
那么,
小孩子都要着急，
做洋气的车子呀，
对,
而且,
他们也没有那么守规矩嘛，
对,
就是,
大家非常自由，
就往车上，
那样一坐，
对,
管它是什么，
嗯,
而且,
无论是，
上海人，
还是苏州河，
你去翻路元敏的，
照片,
它其实，
很多时候，
场景元素，
是重复出现的，
你是能，
潜意识的感觉到，
这个地方很大，
很多样，
我要让每张不重复，
而是,
你知道这个摄影师，
是在差不多一样的地方，
反反复复的拍，
然后持续的拍了，
很大量的东西，
那这个时候，
其实在观看的，
潜意识中，
会让观众，
被带入到说，
更信任这个画面，
更觉得这个摄影师，
确实是在，
向你传递上海，
而不是在，
向你传递一个，
修饰更多的上海，
对,
而且我觉得就是，
虽然,
罗元明他是一个上海人，
但是你在看他的照片的时候，
你不会觉得，
他在刻意美化这个城市，
对,
他就是在，
很真实的去记录，
但是,
因为可能是他，
作为一个上海人，
他带有上海的精神，
他更懂得，
这里面的风土，
所以他所看到的那个世界，
他所捕捉的这个画面的视角，
包括这个倾斜的角度，
他可能就是，
更上海一点，
或者说，
更了解上海一点的人，
是更能接受的，
对,
我觉得风土摄影是有这个特点，
就是说，
他,
首先的，
预设的观众，
他最适配的观众，
其实是本地人，
对,
他能够调动起，
比如说你曾经在，
苏州河畔走过的人们的那种记忆，
对,
因为本身，
我们给，
风土摄影的定义，
他一定要有向内的那个环节，
但是如果对于一个，
只关注外部世界的，
就是说，
如果你是烈奇系的，
观众的心态的话，
其实是不在意，
向内观看这个事情的，
那是多余的信息，
那是,
很容易就被当作造声，
给忽略掉的部分，
是的,
对,
其实最能，
读懂一个好的风土摄影的，
往往一定是本地观众最优先，
但是对于，
非本地的观众，
风土摄影也是，
非常有意义的，
甚至说，
它是很珍贵的一种东西，
就是说，
你可以通过，
摄影这么一个，
很残缺，
或者间接的信息，
被带到一个，
比如作为一个，
外国人，
外地人，
很难,
触及到的，
本地人的精神世界，
在那里生活中的世界里，
这个是风土摄影，
对于,
在这个地域以外的人，
很重要的那个意义，
是的,
好,
那说完了上海的，
风土摄影，
我们正好，
今年在，
Cutography的时候,。
也关注了一位摄影师，
也是一个日本的，
女性摄影师，
我觉得他也是非常，
可以被划分到，
我们这个风土摄影的，
类别当中的，
当代风土摄影，
优秀摄影师，
对对对，
一体优秀的那种，
对,
然后我觉得，
也可以和大家介绍一下，
他就是柴田早礼，
柴田早礼这个摄影师，
其实我们在京都国际摄影节，
的前瞻导栏里，
就提到过他，
那我们为什么要把，
柴田早礼这个项目，
放在这里介绍给大家，
非常正宗的介绍给大家，
是因为他的这个项目，
在拍风土这个事情上，
拍出了一个新高度，
他给大家，
秀出一个风土摄影，
起码很难，
之前被想到的一个角度，
对,
那他拍了一个，
什么样的项目呢？
那让我来，
先慢慢给大家介绍一下，
这个项目的背景，
这个京都国际摄影节，
每年会有一些奖项的评选，
那其中有一个奖项的，
获得者呢，
是可以获得，
为期一个月的，
南法注地创作机会，
在一个长期赞助，
京都国际摄影节的，
这个酒庄里面，
嗯,
然后柴田早礼呢，
在2025年,
获得了这个机会，
去创作了一个月，
所以他这个项目的，
2026年,
就拿出来展出了，
这个我们在京都的这个，
导览节目里，
也讲到过，
是,
因为我们之前，
也看过很多这个，
注地创作，
就,
大家也可以想象，
对,
就懂得都懂，
对吧,
他注地创作，
还在一个酒庄里，
然后,
毕竟人家要赞助的，
那其实，
对于创作者，
限制比较淡，
是,
你很难把，
很多个人的东西出来，
你可能很多人都会，
去拍那片土地，
去拍那片葡萄糖，
去拍这个，
酿酒的，
过程,
对,
拍当地酿酒师傅，
是怎么劳作的，
对,
就是,
没办法嘛，
对,
但是,
拆迁早里，
今年,
就是震惊我们，
一整年的这个，
拍法,
首先就不一样，
他的那个展，
我记得是，
我们看完了之后，
真的是，
记忆超级深刻的，
然后,
不亚于，
我们之前给大家介绍的，
很多大事的作品，
甚至,
我们看完了之后，
又回到东京，
又看了一遍，
他在东京的，
关联展览，
对,
然后,
当时我们还想着说，
如果他有，
作品在售卖的话，
都藏他的作品，
买一副他的原作，
是,
就到了这种程度，
对,
所以就是，
我们对他的评价，
非常高的，
然后,
为什么评价这么高啊，
就是因为他在，
这个,
注定创作的项目里，
是在太秀了，
他,
把自己的家乡，
秀进了，
在南法的，
注定创作里，
那这是怎么做到的，
我来给大家，
解释一下啊，
非常难以，
难以,
难以用一句话形容，
对,
他太精妙了，
那,
整个是一个，
非常精妙的设计，
首先,
有一个概念，
小河,
大家补充说明一下，
不知道，
大家有没有听过，
日本有一个，
著名的民意大师，
叫柳宗月，
柳宗月这个人，
是这个，
二十世纪，
初的,
人物,
他,
撰写了很多，
关于日本民意的书籍，
去为,
日本当代的，
这个民意，
做了很多，
电机的工作，
是,
他是一个，
非常重要的美学家，
思想家，
觉得,
然后他，
其实对于，
现在日本的很多，
将人精神，
手作,
他们的这些，
气物,
都是有着，
非常重要的，
影响的，
对,
所以他呢，
在,
当年就，
有利了，
整个日本，
去观察，
考察,
各个地方的，
风土人情，
对,
然后,
体恋出那个地方，
是有什么，
风土人情，
好的这种，
气物,
对,
其实他也是在，
一个,
发学和，
归纳,
整理日本的，
文化的，
这样一个过程，
对,
然后,
柳宗月，
在他诸多的，
这个美学理论里面，
有一个词，
很重要，
叫做,
土德,
土,
是土地的土德，
是德行的德，
对,
又是汉字，
有一天，
他就有利到了，
这个,
日本的富山县，
京都在，
往北,
卖过,
那么,
一些山脉，
你才能到达的，
靠近日本，
西海洋的地方，
那个地方呢，
他有利了，
当时的，
这个,
南历市的，
风土人情之后，
称赞当地，
是非常有土德的，
然后,
那么,
柳宗月是怎么，
解释他对，
土德这个定义呢，
他说,
土德是由，
首先是，
当地的这个，
自然环境，
和人共生，
然后一起，
创作出的一个，
呃,
类似于，
意识的集合的那个，
感觉,
而且这种，
意识的集合呢，
在一种，
不加修饰的情况下，
朴素的展现给了大家，
嗯,
只有在这种情况下，
他才会，
称呼这个地方，
有土德，
所以他的土德，
是不是还包含了，
当地的信仰这个，
概念,
对呀,
就是因为，
当地人的精神活动，
这种宗教祭祀活动，
肯定跟你，
这个地方的历史，
跟这个地方的自然，
是连接在一起的，
嗯,
就是一个信仰，
就是他，
很多元化的一个状态，
嗯,
就是他可以，
比如在，
山区的地方，
那你就更多的信仰，
山西的神明一点，
嗯,
然后在水和海多的地方，
你会反过去，
信仰那边的神明，
多一点点，
那肯定信仰，
也包含在其中的，
是,
嗯,
所以南丽呢，
在柳宗月倒访之后呢，
就,
作用了土德这个美名，
啊,
就是全日本，
最有土德的一个地方，
嗯,
对,
柳宗月当时，
最南丽县这个地方，
它有什么特殊之处，
能让柳宗月觉得，
是非常拥有土德的呢？
嗯,
这个其实说出来，
可能像一个笑话一样，
就是可能，
稍微有一点，
不容易被人理解，
嗯,
因为南丽市的人呢，
其实一直是，
按照自己的生活节奏去过的，
但是他们一直会有一些，
很朴素的，
类似于信仰，
或者说信念的成分在里面，
啊,
首先他们，
在民意这个事情，
有自己的特产，
他们会有，
很不错的这个雕刻，
然后合纸，
还有麻布的这个，
传统的工艺，
然后同时，
他们自己的那个生活状态，
就是生活方式，
对,
现在的话，
可能是生活方式，
他们会认为，
比如都市是人造的，
但是乡村是神造的，
啊,
他们会很敬畏，
或者说，
就是那种，
日本的村庄文化，
嗯,
它对于自己的这个，
地方的整体的那种，
精神性，
有一种，
非常高的共鸣感，
嗯,
在里面的，
然后呢，
对于柳宗月来说，
她来到南丽之后呢，
她接触了，
哦,
原来南丽人都，
这个样子，
他们的精神在某一个地方，
都像连接到一起，
然后共同构成了，
南丽这个地方，
对,
然后又跟这个自然，
融合得很好嘛，
嗯,
然后所以在这个情况下，
柳宗月就受到了，
这种风土的感召，
受到了，
感染,
对于这个东西的震撼，
然后她又说，
这个地方有土德，
到现在为止呢，
就是南丽人会说，
我们这个地方有土德，
他们很自豪，
对，很自豪，
但是,
他们会说，
其实什么是具体的土德，
每个人会有自己不同的理解，
哦,
但是你到了南丽之后，
你就能，
呃,
体验到这个事情了，
哇,
还挺想去，
对,
就,
那么,
田天早里就是一个南丽人，
啊,
怪不得，
然后,
所以,
土德呢，
就是,
根始与他的主堂，
也是无条件的根治，
在他身上的，
所以说，
他后来是跑到，
东京的大学去念大学，
然后又跑去IT公司，
去做金融工作，
哦,
他是一个很标准的，
就是,
过过现代日子的人，
他不是，
大家想象的是，
一个村民的那个状态，
哦,
他对于，
对,
他的很多，
嗯,
他都能搞得很清楚。
他说他去上班就是深入的了解了。
现代社会的这些运行等等的。
所以这样的一个出身在南丽县的柴田早里。
那么他跑到法国的酒庄做的这个在地创作项目的名字。
就叫土德之日
叫Dotokudes。
对 就是他
这就是土德
你刚才讲了一个谐音歌。
Dotokudes。
但是他那个Days是那个Days。
很多天的那个Days。
柴田早里这个项目其实还深度合。
他当时在京都展出的这个展馆做了一个适配。
然后他大概是分了三层去做了一个递进的感觉。
那在第一层就是大家刚刚进这个展厅的时候。
观众会看到很多代表新生的那个东西。
就比如说很多是幼儿小孩子。
然后还有比如一些新发芽的枝叶。
比如说一些这种代表着新生的意义在里面。
对
然后是会比较简单化一点的那个。
你感觉生命力很强的感觉。
这个时候就看到我们已经开始有一些精差了。
但在这个注定创作中。
他不仅用了在法国拍的照片。
他还用了他在南丽拍的很多照片。
但是你会傻傻分不清楚。
你不会觉得这就是法国。
这就是日本
对
然后其中有很多就是和纸叠成的小物件。
比如说他拿和纸剪了一个小嫩叶子的形状。
然后放到一个不知道是。
法国的叶子的旁边。
对 他放到应该是那个葡萄藤那边的叶子里。
然后他拍下来
就仿佛是他把他家乡的这个传统。
就是和纸
对
这一份土德
这一份封土
带去了他所有利的或短暂停留的法国酒妆里。
这一点就让你觉得土德这个概念。
确实很清晰的已经开始展现了。
就是柴天早里
他会觉得自己本身就是土德的一部分。
因为就是在南丽人心中。
人和封土是分不开的一个东西。
其实你不在南丽
你也是一个南丽人。
你也是一个南丽的封土。
你也是南丽土德的一部分。
对
你看到的景象
你去对这个世界的认知。
依旧带有南丽土德的那个特征。
是的
对
然后再往上到了第二层的展览里。
就从那种新生的生命的感觉。
到了一种社会化的感觉。
你会更多的看到
比如一张南丽祭典的图片。
大家穿着和服
然后包着头巾走在街上的那个样子。
然后下一张是
应该是法国的酒妆的这个田梗上。
然后工作宝的那个工人也是包着头巾。
然后就坐在那里
做成一排非常整齐。
就像祭典时的那个对列一样。
然后可能一层你看到的。
核质的小道具是叶子。
然后到了二层就变成了小鸟。
小精灵吃的东西
对
有点卡通的那种感觉。
但是你以后一下就认知了。
这是一个日本的核质。
做的一个东西
是
但是又没有伟和感。
对
它那个核质又是白色的。
然后整个白色的简直。
放到它那个很自然的环境当中。
一片绿色当中
你又觉得我是一种全新的影像风格。
又形成了柴天藻礼个人的风格。
对
那是非常它个人的东西。
但是你在它的创作理念里去看。
它又是一个非常土德的东西。
是
那到了第二层
其实会出现很多
就是比如柴天藻礼的自拍的感觉。
就比如说一层是那种。
像穿着樱桃小丸子一样的。
那个小女孩在田间。
然后模糊的身影的那种照片。
然后到了二层
可能就是柴天藻礼。
自己穿上了
自己在高中时候穿过的那种制服。
然后站在法国的田间。
然后去拍的自拍
它想表达的可能是。
比如男力的一个少女。
也依然会出现在男法的一个地方。
就是因为他这个人。
所以男力一直跟随他。
有可能是他在少女时代。
他在男力的时候
就曾梦想来到法国。
对
像我们这种女孩子。
可能年轻的时候
都会有这种梦想
然后他长大之后
他来到了
但是他又仿佛毁到了。
少女时期的自己
但是他又真实的
站在了法国的那个土地。
对
然后所以他这个项目。
你听到这里
他已经非常巧妙的把。
男力和男法这两个地方。
融合到了一级
星耿
对 就是他无法分割。
就是在画面上
在这个项目里
在整个展览的观看上。
你觉得这个东西融合得好棒。
有强烈的个人风格。
但是又是一个
标准的在地创作
这有一种河南人
到了河南的感觉
我觉得所有河南人都可以用。
这种创作方法
然后去河南拍反
我觉得确实其实河南。
和河南有很多相似的地方。
对
是
一定会有的
对
其实我觉得特别感动的是。
我们还没解读完
我们只刚到二层
刚到这一层
我觉得就是
给了我一个启发
就是你无论走到哪。
你确实都是
会带有你家乡
故乡
或者你所成长的那个地方的。
一些土德的这样的一个人。
然后你都可以
把你的土德
带去世界的任何一个地方。
但是他又是一个
很美妙的融入感觉。
就是你并不是说
我走到哪
而我都是哪的人
因此有一个主客之分。
对
我觉得这是柳宗月的土德。
和比如中文的风土人情。
所有点不一样的那个感觉。
土德的那个融合性。
会感觉更强
就是他不会强调说。
这个人如果离开了这个地方。
他就很难以展现出。
这个地方的全部土德。
对
然后让我们来到第三层。
那第三层的展览
就更加的厉害
之前你看到
这个核质的一些形象。
就又进化成了
更加抽象的状态
比如他可能进化成。
像灵魂的那种水滴的那种造型。
然后你会看到更多。
就是比如巫女
在红面上跳舞的那个状态。
就是他更多的
进入了一种精神领域。
在描绘的是
人与自然的精神融合。
就是按中国传统的。
观众角度
可能会觉得有一点阴奸。
对 甚至有一种就是轮回感。
或者如果你从一楼开始解读。
那就是从今生到青壮年。
然后最后可能到老年。
甚至死亡的这样的一个表达。
对 最终进入到了一种灵魂的境界。
是非常纯粹的画面。
出现在你的眼前
对
他可能是有四楼
还是三楼有一个特别大的一幅。
就是你会感觉到
那是他最终想引导你到的那种。
单纯只有精神存在的世界。
是
只有概念在哪里
然后这个精神又是很多人。
所共同构成的
然后他随着
一代又一代人的轮替。
他又会融合到这个地方的土德里。
风土里
对
所以他其实就是通过这个项目。
通过他去南法的酒庄的一个住地。
他把整个柳宗月和南丽式的。
这个土德的这个概念。
给产数的特别好
对 而且是那种过目不忘级别的。
就是我相信每一个人看过之后。
他都会说
我一定要去南丽看一下这个东西。
对
而且就是你可以深挖很多。
或者说你从不同的角度去拆解。
去分析
都很爽
我觉得就是一个看了很爽的一个摄影展。
对
然后包括法国人
其实也非常爱他这个展览。
像在这个展我们去的时候。
一楼会有一个法国男人。
他应该是酒庄那边的负责人。
然后他会很热情的操着琉璃的日语。
然后慢慢的用日语给你讲。
整个项目的背景
作者是怎么想的
就是你能看到这个法国人。
超级沉浸在这个项目里。
对
我觉得这个就是土德和土德之间的连接。
对 他超越了就是传统 地点 实体。
也具象的风光
对人的那个束缚和连接的那种固定的公式。
对
你一下就来到了一种就是。
确实土德
你开始理解这个精神状态是很美妙的。
是
就是精神连接可以超越很多。
物理上的现实中的画面里的限制。
对
那如果对这个项目感兴趣的朋友。
其实可以在我们的收脑词里。
看到一些这些展览上出现过的图片。
同时我还会放一个连接在里面。
它是京都国际摄影节官方给这个项目做的连接。
然后你在页面的最下方。
其实是能找到一个云看展的这么一个窗口的。
然后你可以感受到整个空间的排布。
是不是像我们所说的一样整个三层楼的地近。
然后很多作品的分布是什么样子的。
因为其实现场的布展比我们刚刚讲的。
还要再丰富 再有设计一点。
也是柴天早里和一个建筑师。
两个人很认真一起做出来的。
对 我觉得尤其是对于那种。
特别想做一个自己的展览的朋友。
你可以就是非常全面的去看一下。
对 然后我刚才在讲完这个项目之后。
就去看了一下柴天早里的这个blog。
然后我发现他还提到了一个很重要的创作的细节。
就是说他画面中出现的所有的女性形象。
其实全部都是他自己一个人去出境完成的。
都是他合成的嘛 就后期做的。
对 就比如我们看到那个。
如果大家去云看着。
能看到那个带着头巾。
然后背对着镜头的在南法田尖。
小女孩
劳作的妇女也好
或者穿着水手服两个站在田里背对着镜头的少女也好。
都是柴天早里自己一个人。
然后换上不同的服装。
然后把自己拍下来。
然后最终在合成镜画面里的。
然后但是我们在现场看的时候。
其实感受不到那个合成的痕迹。
总之他这个合成的活是做得非常细的。
然后包括最后一层在水边的那个。
看上去有点中老年的妇女的形象也是他自己。
也是他自己
包括那个手拉着手在那个类似于虎面上。
然后很幽灵摄影的那个巫女形象。
应该也是他自己
那这个挺帅的
所以他等于是
他最终也没有很清晰的去跟你讲说。
哪张照片的哪个元素是什么时候在什么地点拍的。
但是他应该还是用上了很多自己的元素。
以及自己拍摄过的照片。
然后形成了这个项目。
然后这个项目
现在只能在京都国际盛节的官方页面上。
看到尽量多一点的信息。
然后在他个人网站上。
其实都没有显示到这个项目的。
这个创作背景等等的。
所以其实说到这儿。
我觉得一是柴天早里这个摄影师非常推荐给大家去关注。
我觉得他非常年轻。
而且他从他这几年的创作来看我进步飞快。
而且就是我觉得相对于过往的一些日本摄影师。
他又上升了一个维度。
对
他在追求精神文明这件事的这个表述上好像更好。
确实可能跟他是男力人有关系。
对 就是男力的土德在指引着他。
对 没有什么东京人那么容易急躁和焦虑是吧？
对
还有一个点我的一个感触就是。
其实东方人
特别是中国人非常适合用风土摄影的这种感觉去表达。
对 因为其实东方人认识世界的这个角度。
和西方人是有很大差异的。
对
东方人他能很自然的就是天生就能理解一个整体的概念。
就比如说我们讲北京这个城市。
在你脑中的第一反应肯定不是一个地点。
然后也不是一堆建筑也不是一个历史。
他会是很复杂的一个概念。
对
东方人更容易理解概念的集合这个东西。
他也更愿意相信就比如说。
我在说一个事情的时候他认为他是一个充满关联性的。
然后充满角度要多维度去理解的。
然后是一个复杂理念的东西。
这是东方人东方文化的一个根基。
对
有阴有阳对吧？
对 就是什么东西都可以让他变得更复杂一点的这个感觉。
是的
然后而且中国又是真的有很多风土。
有很多的民族的文化所构成的。
然后可能每一个小的城市。
你都会有自己的那份土德。
对 其实那个土德。
中国这么大他的土德的多样性肯定是很多的。
是
而且是很容易被画面所表达出来的。
是的
但是大家还很少的去以这种理念去表述一个地方。
对
而且我觉得风土摄影它是可以跨越人跟人之间的那种不理解。
是的
然后包括比如说什么地域歧视。
或者说什么攀比
就是这些很现实的一些问题的。
对 其实让人和人互相接纳的方法。
并不是让这两个人觉得彼此是一样的。
因为人和人再怎么着都能找出不同。
更容易找出不同
但是你能真诚的更全面的把你的生活展示给另外一个人的时候。
我们的交情一定会挺好。
是的
而且我觉得就是风土摄影。
刚才我们说到的可能更多是创作者的视角。
其实我们呼吁大家可以从这个角度去创作。
如果你是一个摄影师的话。
那做一个观看者
我觉得我们确实也可以通过这种方式。
然后去观看别人的生活。
如果有更多的人能够拍出自己的风土。
然后让更多的人去观看。
世界就会多一份理解少一些隔阂。
那说完了柴仙早里的展览。
我们可以再来聊一个我们最近新看的展览。
对 我觉得也是非常能代表我们所说的风土摄影的一个。
怎么说的一个方向。
然后这个展览是北京三云堂。
从8月1号开始的一个新的展览。
然后它的创作者叫拱月。
然后它的身份非常的特殊。
它是我们的听众
对 但不止如此
它是北京市东城区长安门地区的一个民警。
就是那种高大威梦。
会来你家敲闻的那种民警。
对 但是它很nice。
但是它的身材就是一看就非常有安全感。
反复是一个美国警察的那种壮硕的。
对 就不是北京那种距离传统的。
一个个受的跟葛优似的。
然后晃晃带个帽子。
它就是那种特别惊干的。
然后特别现代的那种警察。
非常自信的警察叔叔。
但是这个小哥哥不是叔叔对不起。
然后这个小哥哥他虽然是个警察。
但是他本身的专业其实一直都是学美术的。
而且他还是专业学社营的。
首先他是国家高级摄影师。
然后他先后毕业于北京电影学院图片摄影专业。
以及中央美术学院摄影专业。
总之就很专业的
他是一个专业学艺术的。
学艺术学摄影的人。
然后他作为一个警察。
同时也是一个影像创作者。
专业的艺术家
然后他其实就是用这种双重视角在观察世界。
然后大家知道就是北京的民警。
就是我们叫片警
其实是和老百姓的关系非常近的。
家里有什么事
可能警察就可以来上门。
然后像我小时候我们住胡同里。
我们街坊就是警察。
警察就和我们住医院里。
就是街坊
然后他没事的时候。
就可能就坐院子旁边。
又跟我们喝茶吃西瓜。
就是这样
反正是非常亲密的那种关系。
不是说你觉得警察很恐怖。
然后只有发生杀人案的时候才是住医院那种。
对
你查身份证的时候也贵。
你家里有什么事你都可以找警察。
真的吗？
真的呀？
我觉得很多地方都是这样的。
然后那孔岳其实花了一年多的时间。
然后去了100多个家庭里。
然后拍了300多个人物。
300多个居民
那他这个还挺高产的。
是的
他一年能拍出300多。
就算300多张正式能编进去的照片。
这个量你平均算他一天一张的也不小。
是
那让我们回到孔岳的展览里。
其实他这次展出的照片。
大家也可以在shownotes里看一下。
都是他拍摄这些居民。
在这些居民的家中。
或者日常经常活动的地方。
比如小区里面
这些地方然后去拍摄的这个相像照片。
然后其实他的这个购图也非常简单。
然后都是人物在画面中央。
然后或者在比较标准的。
就是左三分之一有三分之一这种位置。
然后拍了好之后
用一个比较小的光圈。
去拍出一个景深很深的。
在每张照片让你能看到。
图中更多的人物信息。
物品信息和环定信息。
当我们在现场看这个照片的时候。
其实能感觉到他拍摄很不容易。
因为首先每张照片里。
你能感觉到这个背景还是用心整理过的。
首先你家里平时生活的状态。
其实很难直接让人上门来拍照。
同时呢就是不仅
已经算是收拾的很利索。
还要展现出每个出境人物的性格。
这个空间里
因为我在现场看每张照片的时候。
当然大家在网上也可以看到。
就是他的每张照片里。
其实在人物以外的空间里都充斥着。
对这个人物的补充说明。
或者是一种引导
你能看出这个人的爱好是什么？
他平时的工作
或者是看到他的一种生活状态。
是什么样子的
对
就比如说我们如果去拍一个老人的时候。
其实老人在他的这次展览里。
有一些就是会选择展示爱好。
有一些展示的是自己退休前的职业。
有一些展示的是一种自己的精神状态。
是
我觉得有合唱团的老人们。
老宋队
其实很多北京的退休的老人。
他们都有自己的群体。
类似科爱巴尔是个这种小组织。
然后而且是穿着的。
非常地统一的这场亮丽。
即使是岁数挺大的阿姨。
他们可能都会有比较精致的妆容。
是的
而且他们所展示的这些东西。
是很个人化的那一面。
对
比如说他在拍摄这个人的时候。
他更多的喜欢说
去给观众交代一下他有什么爱好。
或者说他曾经是一个什么样的职业。
就是他们的档案吗？
对
就像档案
所以我觉得这个也是拱月。
作为有双重身份的创作者的一个优势。
就是
因为你去做一个摄影的项目。
尤其你去做一个展。
你真的要展现很大的信息量出来的。
然后如果你想表现一个地方的风土。
一个像他的主题叫社区笑相。
就关于朝阳门地区的人们的精神状态和生活。
你真的就是要很会抓取物证。
现场
而且整理
现场是有很多物证和档案袋的。
是
就是拱月去准备了比如说一些视频。
然后在现场用一个很老的CRT电视机。
然后在这放
然后同时他还会把档案袋以那个夹板的形式加到墙上。
对
然后还放了很多那种6寸的照片。
然后就比较随意的放在那。
你可以随便反
对
就是这个证据量非常的充足。
足以证明他说的是实话。
对
而且我相信就是
就是拱月是和这些人们300多个人关系是很好的。
就是你一定能感受到拱月是一个非常亲民的警察。
对
因为我能记得很多画面里的那个老人也好。
年轻人也好
他愿意把自己非常个人的爱好的那一面。
然后去铺成在整个画面里展示给大家看。
对
而且因为当时我们去了他的开幕的仪式。
就现场你知道吗？
有很多被他拍摄的叔叔阿姨就特别热情的跑去那个三领堂去看展。
然后还去拿着画筒去讲说当时骨月怎么给我们拍的。
他是多好多好
就是我觉得这种热情是社区肖像。
或者说我们刚刚提到这个风土摄影能够带来的这种情感。
其实这个挺难得的。
因为三领堂其实在北京很偏僻的一个地方。
对
然后你必须要只能用打车的方式。
可以开车
对
总之你需要一辆车。
他没有公交
没有地铁
对
然后你必须从超门过去怎么着也要半个多小时。
可能读点车40分钟才能到的一个距离。
所以那天有很多社区居民。
因为从超门过去看我觉得确实也证明。
他们关系非常好
不是
不是背负
对
然后另外就是除了这一点之外。
我觉得拱月他为什么这个项目让我觉得特别风土呢？
是因为我觉得北京很适合他这样的拍法。
对
他真的是就是很理解这个事情。
因为北京这个城市。
他在展示一个人的生活的时候。
很难用上海那种人在公共空间里发生的行为。
让你独到生活感
北京这个城市到现在为止。
它都是一个
封闭性的
封闭性很强的地方有很多的围墙。
加丑不能外扬
就是北京是一个更多人的生活的个性的那一面。
要出现在自己家里的那么一个状态。
北京这个城市就确实是更容易在屋子里面拍出一个人的性格的那个地方。
对
就跟胡同也是这样的。
你在胡同外面你会觉得这个世界非常的安静。
但是院子里面又是非常的热闹的。
对
然后每个人的平均的那个屋子可能都比较小。
因为正好长安门内那边是胡同区。
然后老房子区域
它是一个人均面积比较小的一个地块。
然后在那里你能看到的那种景象是非常北京化的。
就是每个人拥有的空间不大。
但是堆得很满
它基本上它个人的爱好。
它的性格填满了整个空间。
对 是的
这个其实是我很佩服这些被拍摄者的那个点。
就是它对自己的生活还是有很强的管理能力的。
以及它有很多的精力投入到这里面去。
才能把这个东西做那么满。
是
而且我觉得就是我作为一个观众。
我去看他的作品的时候。
真的是看到的一个又一个具体的人。
和他所生活的那个屋子。
然后在这个屋子所构成的这些整体。
又确实又非常的长安门 非常的东城。
就比如说我们能看到它的。
所以我们西城不那么生活是吗？
它有微妙的差别
但是至于西城什么样。
咱们还没有西城的风土摄影。
咱们还有带挖掘
咱们就只说东城
就是你比如说你看拱月儿照片里面。
你能看到这个龙夫寺。
对
然后你会看到一些胡同的痕迹。
很多胡同的痕迹
对吧？
你知道就是确实长安门有很多外国人。
没错
所以其实这也是我们觉得很风土的一种摄影。
因为作为北京人
我们在看到这个展览的时候。
会直接联想起一种人在北京生活的。
这种体验或者说精神状态。
它不会是那种很遥远的。
我觉得这里的人怎么这样。
怎么这么生活
它好奇怪
它不会勾起人们这样的想法。
我觉得拱月儿的作品特别好的一个点。
它不是说北京人
它没有把这个主体扣在北京人上。
它扣的是这个社区。
那你不会关注说它的户籍是哪。
就是它身份证号是哪。
它不会存在什么地域歧视的这些问题。
那就是所有生活在这个社区里的人。
无论他是从哪里来的。
他是外地人也好
他是别的区的人也好。
或者他是外国人也好。
他都构成了这个社区。
对
我觉得社区文化其实应该是这个样子的。
而不是说北京人就得是怎么怎么着。
就得吃什么？
就得穿什么？
就得操制怎样的口音。
他讨论的不是这件事。
对
因为比如我们前面讲。
陆元敏的拍的上海很好。
但是他的拍的上海是。
可能二三十年前的一个状态了。
而且还是黑白摄影。
所以你在看的时候。
你能感受到上海的风土。
但是会有一些时间的隔阂。
但是比如到拱月这里。
他所拍摄的是
现在的当下的在北京生活的人。
所以他给我的触动。
是拱月在认真的为北京的。
现在而去留下一些影像。
而去努力
而且就是说他会
因为我能看到这些照片。
我觉得北京还有一些火力在里面。
然后我们在现场就跟拱月聊天。
然后他就说他这回。
主要用的就是家能五第四拍的。
然后他觉得可能输出之后。
因为他做展了
做展输出其实服面挺大的。
他有的可能是一米二成八十。
所以还是一个大幅的输出了。
对 然后他就说他之后。
还想换更好的相机。
想继续拍
然后他想拍北京更多的地方。
更多的家庭
所以我就觉得
这是一个特别好的开始。
然后我就跟他说
因为我之前一直很在谋划一个。
关于北京的一个项目。
但是我就说我当时拍过一遍。
我就不满意
我就放弃了
我就想重新拍
但是我还是没有拍完。
我不像拱月一样
就是已经能够非常自信的。
非常确定的把一个项目完成。
然后但是我这回看了。
他的展览之后
就是他给了我一种激励。
就是说我长大之后。
我也会有新的社会的身份。
我也可能像他一样是。
用双重的视角身份。
在这个世界上活着的。
就是我会更有信心去好好地拍摄。
而且可能是从风土摄影这个视角。
去拍摄我想要记录的风土。
就是其实我们之前。
在很多节目里也讲过。
比如上海他之所以。
是一个对摄影文化很友好。
然后拥有很多摄影历史的城市。
是因为有很多上海人。
到现在都在坚持拍上海。
对 也有很多爱好者。
对 就是他们对于拍上海。
是一种无条件的
并不是说我要去
怎么说呢？
我要去马上做一个展。
要出名
我是一个大摄影师。
而是说他认为拍摄上海。
是一个他很喜欢的事情。
他就去做了
然后像广越他也是这个状态。
实际上他就是一个北京人。
他对他的工作
对他熟悉的这个土地。
他是有感情
然后有拍摄的热情的。
是
对 所以我觉得
只有每个地方都有这种。
本地摄影师拍的本地封土。
才能让这个地方对摄影这个事情。
产生更多的热情
才有可能有更多的好摄影师。
被大家认可
对
然后像我们最近
其实在北京待的时间比较长嘛？
之前我们其实
总觉得北京没有什么摄影文化。
然后我们也没有
特别多的摄影的活动可以参加。
这回看了广越的展览。
就觉得 哇 原来。
北京还有这样的社区效项。
这样的项目
这样的
甚至是一个民间小哥哥。
他都在创作
我觉得这种创作的热情。
就非常能感染我
然后包括比如说
还像我们之前
节目里会来的王婷老师。
她在努力的做摄影书。
然后像编画23
她也生活在北京
周末我还可以去个三景堂。
去看个摄影展
然后当这些东西
越来越多的时候
然后我可能作为一个。
无论是创作者也好。
还是摄影的爱好者也好。
我就会在这个氛围中。
得到很多的支撑
就是我会感受到那个土德的。
或者说风土的力量。
他能够鼓励我去创作。
只有更多的人
去以风土摄影的方式。
去记录他所生活的这个地方。
他身边的这些人
或者说他所喜欢的文化。
我觉得更有风格的。
更属于我们自己的这种摄影。
才会诞生出来吧？
好的 以上就是本期节目的主要内容。
然后如果大家喜欢的话。
欢迎在评论区和我们互动。
然后也欢迎大家点赞。
转发 甚至赞赏
好的 让我们来到。
每期节目必备的彩蛋环节。
然后那么今天的彩蛋环节。
让我们来小小的开展一点。
摄影批评
对 虽然很多朋友喜欢听我们。
但是我们这个都放到彩蛋了。
它也不是一个正式的。
也不是一个正式的批评。
但是我们依然认为。
摄影批评还是非常重要的。
有朝一日可能我们就开一个专栏。
对 摄影批评其实在摄影比较成熟的。
摄影文化比较发达的地方吧？
还是很常见的一个东西。
对
然后它也不是吵架。
或者说我要贬低谁。
我觉得不是这样的。
大家就当作是什么网友评论。
就是说这个东西如果这么拍。
会不会更好
是
而且我觉得就算是被批评。
所谓批评其实是一种讨论。
就是被批评和被讨论的艺术家。
或者创作者
你即使听到了别人对你的批评。
也是一个好事
就说明你的作品还是受到更多的关注了。
而且其实很多批评不一定是对你不好。
就是是对你的抨击。
而且我相信很多艺术家。
是非常大度的
它是可以接纳不同的声音的。
我们就正好聊聊
最近一些关于拍摄上海的项目吧？
因为我最近总是会有一些上海的朋友。
他们就是上海人
顺势等等
就跟我说
哎呀这个项目好烂。
就是怎么能这样拍上海呢？
真的受不了
然后还有一些
那个UP主什么也会发视频。
对
就是
因为上海确实是一个非常值得被拍摄的对象。
而且自带流量嘛？
而且很多人都在拍嘛？
然后这个时候
如果出了一个拍上海的影集。
大家关注度首先很高。
对
然后看完了之后呢？
就是因为参与度也很高。
所以会有人直接批评。
说这个东西拍的不好。
对
然后尤其是对于上海人来讲。
就我也能理解
就是他会觉得你在。
丑化上海
你在泄渡上海
你没有拍出上海的那个很美的。
很现代化的那一面。
但是其实在我们看来的问题。
不是这个角度上的。
他是说
比如当我们对外宣称。
我在拍摄上海的时候。
那我应该反映的是。
这个城市整体的一个样子。
就比如
如果我说上海的问题是。
他在现代化中有很多城市病。
那其实这个主意还是在城市病上。
对
他不是上海的问题。
但是可能很多城市都会有共性的问题。
因为我作为一个创作者。
我想批评的是
你这个城市工程
很多地方做得不对。
这不是上海一个地方会有这种问题。
很多关注这个问题的人。
会很喜欢这个项目。
所以说你看这个人在上海。
发现了这个事情
那我看到这个摄影项目。
会把它推荐给别人。
关起大家对这个问题的共同关注。
我觉得这是一个好的表达方法。
但是如果我拍摄的是。
我认为上海某点不好。
或者我认为上海有一个很奇怪的性格。
但是我说我拍的是上海。
就有一种一篇概权的感觉。
就有一种尤其是上海的观众。
就我觉得说
你又没有很了解上海。
你凭什么定义这里。
对 因为从拍摄的角度。
你也能发现比如这种去。
我们姑且称之为一篇概权。
或者说以点待面
去冒了一个拍上海名头的项目。
它都站在一个很远的拍摄距离上。
它没有去
比如说拍摄上海人。
它没有很近距离的说。
让你在画面中感受到。
上海人的生活是什么样子。
它只能展现一个小小的切片。
然后包括
如果你在上海这座城市生活过。
你会发现它可能拍的风景。
也只是一种结局感的东西。
而不是说还原了一个现实感。
那其实我想这些摄影师。
都是把自己心中的上海投射出来了。
然后跟大家说
这个是我心目中的上海。
那我们要不然就是胆子很大的。
举个例吧？
就是要不然否则
大家觉得我们在打雅鸣。
就比如最近讨论度很高的。
摩登上海这个项目。
它是一本影集
对 我觉得它都叫摩登上海了。
它应该是想展现上海之摩登吧？
但是从画面上来看。
它可能展现的是
它想讽刺一下
它觉得上海不摩登。
因为它的画面其实。
想展示的是上海那种摩登与不摩登。
同时交织在一起
交织在画面里的那个感觉。
它的标题可能就让上海人。
感觉到了一点被冒犯。
就是说你好像在嘲讽我。
挑衅
对 你才挑衅
对 但是它挑衅的这个点。
其实确实又
有一些没太必要
就比如说真正的 provoke。
挑战的是资本主义。
对人生活的影响
然后挑战的是
当时整个社会都很左。
它对于右翼这个东西。
是抱有巨大的怀疑的。
这其实是每个人都怀疑的事情。
你可以去挑衅
但是上海其实
它没什么好挑衅的这个城市。
它就这样了
它就在那了
然后上海也没有逼着。
这个摄影师
或者逼着所有摄影师说。
你只能说上海好 上海摩登。
然后上海的摄影师。
里也不都是摩登的那一面。
摩登的外滩的那个。
包括你看罗元明拍的苏州河。
其实就很平常的河边生活。
只不过这个江面比较大。
这个城市现代一点。
钢铁和工厂多一点。
但是它依然是
不必会展示那种
杂乱感的东西
所以我不知道这个摄影师。
他在嘲讽谁
他在挑衅谁
他在反对什么？
他的这种互相的情绪。
是希望大家去想那个方面的东西。
这个影集我没买
然后但是我看了一下。
就是有人的番说
他拍的上海非常空。
他的画面里是没有人的。
没有什么人
你会有这种感觉
这个反差我还挺觉得。
还挺奇观的
对
他这个就是想用奇观吸引人。
或者你叫安静的上海也可以。
但是不管了反正
人家觉得这东西就磨灯。
这就是磨灯
人家觉得磨灯
对
我的一个很直观的感受。
我觉得他特像外宾的那个视角。
对
就有一种外媒
BBC在报道中国。
时候会出现的上海画面。
那在这里
我再给大家引入一个批评的对象。
就是罗布特凡德修斯特。
他是一个
应该是荷兰人
然后他拍摄了上海很多照片。
其实他拍的很多街拍。
我觉得是没什么？
我想批评的
因为他原来在photograph fisca。
就用街拍照片
办了一个展叫上海瞬间永恒。
我想批评的是
他有一个影集叫中国人家。
他那个就是你说的那种。
他用一种阴间滤镜在拍。
比如他的画面里
他的颜色故意调整过。
就是说他不追求真实感。
我就只能认为说
他想要的这个事儿。
就代表着他认为上海。
应该展现出
他想传递给大家的是。
这样灰萌萌
然后暗曲曲的一个感觉。
当然我不是想强迫。
他拍得特漂亮
我是觉得他可能
构图也太遵循
一些几何上比例的精确。
然后背景里所展示出的那种。
很生活细碎的日常。
是几乎没有的
更多的是非常有指代意义的。
比如一幅装饰画摆在那。
一个毛主席画像摆在那。
然后这个人一定要展现出的是。
一种中国人比较
怎样的姿态
对 而且他的姿态是比较。
怎么说呢 就是
不自然
军制的 就是你看。
你看每个人都是一副。
呃 就是呆呆的
真是管理区
对 有一种瞒目的眼神。
看着你的感觉
像大家想象中的
朝鲜的那种感觉
所以就是
这个你去跟比如
相似拍法的什么？
Tochistel Happy Victim。
包括拱阅的这个
也是大家都是去
一个人间的内部拍了。
一个空间和这个人在一起。
嗯
我就是觉得
罗布特凡德休斯特拍的。
有点过于外边滤镜了。
对
然后那你说
他作为一个创作者。
他脑子里的这个地方就长这样。
他想怎么拍
那OK
但是你也不能说
不允许别人批评你。
你就像BBC
到底什么意图
我觉得
大家都非常清楚
因为图像是非常真实的。
就是他能把你的意图。
非常真实的表露出来的。
对
就比如摩登上海的。
这个摄影师
他之前用空城的视角。
去拍了空城记
是拍东北地区
中国的东北地区
那其实
他的这个时候的表达。
我觉得还是
不会让人觉得
维和感
或者有问题之类的。
就是因为东北本身。
就是一个常年人口。
进流出的地区
然后他所遗留的人类的生活景象。
然后他一直讨论的这种。
就是老龄化
然后城市越来越空心。
然后人越来越少
城市开始瘫痪的
这么一个停留
在过往的
就是辉煌中的那种感觉。
是很适合用空城的视角。
去观察的
而且你人到线下去看。
你会更容易比其他城市。
看到空城的景象
能感觉到
这就是这个地区的。
一个现有的
进行中的生命中的状态。
但是你在上海
你想看到空城
就很短
或者很晚
才能看到这个场景。
那人家可能就觉得。
我就要打破
你们的刻板印象
对
但是你说
当一个摄影师
他不考虑
观众认不认可他
的时候
其实他在秀个人
他在秀个人的审美。
个人的理解
个人的理念
他就不应该拍上海。
他就不应该拍这种。
所有人都会关注到的事物上。
他就应该拍一个
只属于他
对吧？
就更小众一点的东西上。
对
他可能也不设计这个名字。
他就既要又要了
他既想要流量
想要一个共识
但是他又想打破共识。
想打破刻板印象
对吧？
然后他又打破的方法。
所关注的问题
又不是一个问题
就是你说上海这个城市。
你在那生活过的
大家懂的都懂
他有很多缺点
但不是
不是这样的
不是这个画面里的缺点。
对吧？
我希望他们能也把缺点。
拍深刻一点
然后嘲讽说
上海没有那么摩登。
对
然后包括之前
我们说过的
在京都国际摄影节上。
看到的KG Plus。
上面拍摄的
关于黄浦江的项目。
也有很多上海人不喜欢。
对
因为他那个就是更典型的。
就是利用技法
创作语言
然后去套在
每一条河流上
都这么拍一拍
包括这个作者
他自己都承认
他自己没有在上海生活过很久。
他不是很懂上海
然后他依然坚持
以黄浦江做创作
我觉得他也是一种外宾视角。
外宾视角的同时
他以前的项目
你看也是套着拍的。
因为他之前在东京。
也是拍河流
我觉得现在大家对于创作。
做一个摄影项目
好像还是怎么说呢？
要求没有那么严格。
你刚刚说到那个
拍黄浦江的这个摄影师。
他其实没有在上海生活过。
但是他可能花了挺多时间。
去黄浦江周围拍摄。
但是这就够了吗？
我想问
这不够
你可能真的要花挺长时间。
如果你想拍这个主题。
你想拍一个和风土有关的。
一个主题一个项目的话。
你真的要花挺长时间的。
你起码要真实的
与这里的人接触
你要感受这里的气候。
你可能要因为这个气候的变化。
而生过病
然后你可能要买过几轮衣服等等。
甚至你要学会在这个地方。
生存下去吗？
我觉得可能是现在的摄影师。
不用太在意
严谨性的这个问题了。
就是他们项目的名字吗？
对
就比如说他这个名字起的都很随意。
比如摩登上海
肯定有更好的奇法。
让大家理解他像表达的东西的。
不能像二三一样吗？
你看人家那个半只浪。
每个字都是用内涵的。
但是当然半只浪也不好理解。
都是浪
但他很好记忆
对很好记忆
现在在一个系列策划项目策划上。
可能年轻的摄影师。
或者有一些摄影师吧？
他就是不喜欢讲的这个事。
就比如说我们前面说。
那个荷兰摄影师
他要拍中国人家
他要用这个标题
他就是觉得我
以一种游客的姿态。
或者以一种烈期的姿态。
拍了这个项目发了就是OK的。
然后我们比如说
有一些摄影师不喜欢。
包括我不喜欢
那是因为我不是这样的摄影师。
我觉得这也是
现在这个时代的运行规则。
我觉得上海就是有很多人会。
反改或者讨论
一些摄影项目是一个。
特别牛的事
你知道为什么吗？
就是说明上海的摄影。
已经进入到了一个新的。
就是更卷的一个阶段。
这上海市场
那种在需求摄影批评了。
对 就是他不是说有就行。
就比如说你批评的那个。
荷兰摄影师
他还是处在一个
就是说
反正我拍了
我拍了
就是那就是我的视角。
在记录这个世界了。
但是到现在上海的观众。
或者说摄影爱好者。
已经在挑剔了
已经在评价了
因为大家看得懂
大家知道你在表达什么？
能一眼看穿你的技法。
看穿你不严谨的地方。
对 然后包括比如说。
我们有很多想批评的。
我觉得这种都不算是。
特别严重的问题
那种抄袭的
不告诉你
就是他没有遇上
我们这种眼尖的
就是我一眼能看出来。
你是跟谁抄的
你从哪边影集里抄的哪一张。
有些人他可能
整个系列都抄的一个人。
有些人他可能聪明一点。
抄了好几个人
对吧？
然后构成了他的作品。
这个其实核心还是在于说。
他自己想表达的东西。
是否清晰和独特
或者说有依据 对吧？
既然都有项目介绍这种东西。
很强文本的东西
在现代这个时代
在每一个影集
在每一个帖子里
那摄影师不在意
你就不在意呗
对 那我觉得好的作品。
一定会能沉淀下来。
对吧？
然后即使说
比如说像拱月这种。
他是一个很年轻的摄影师的。
第一次创作的尝试。
你也能从中体验出。
非常好的很美的那个。
价值观和创作的理念。
那这个东西是可以继续下去的。
但有些东西
我觉得是应该被批评的。
或者说随着市场的发展。
随着越来越多的
摄影的观众的成长 对吧？
可能有更多的
坏路写真机的听众 对吧？
眼睛越来越尖
要求越来越高
那这些人
他们就不会被市场所接纳了。
他们就会获得更多的批评。
我想另外一个点
就是可能是近现代的。
这个美术艺术教育有点问题。
就是他告诉艺术家的是。
你所创造的这个东西。
只和你自己有关
然后你不用管别人诈知你。
或者说你不用考虑别人怎么看。
但实际上
就是艺术家想要以艺术的方式活下去。
历史上能养活艺术家的作品。
全都是你要跟时代。
或者跟地方
跟一些支持这个项目。
能理解他的人去产生连接。
让人家喜欢的
现在这个时代
很多时候
媒体院校都在过分的夸大。
对艺术的自由和包容。
因为他们掌握坏权。
对
而且那也是一种白左姿态。
比较流行
世界流行白左
但是接下来
坏权属于人民
人不人民的起码
观众现在很自由
观众的自由
比创作者的自由要大。
对
然后因为观众自由。
所以他们可能获得的信息。
和他的在审美上的进步。
也会更快
他获得信息也会更多。
然后就是我如何去经营。
和观众的关系呢？
如果我想一辈子
从事艺术创作这个事情。
对吧？
那我10年后
我今天的这个项目。
让我支持我的新粉丝看。
是不是一个他们会继续喜欢我的东西。
我要不要以这种
规划商业一样的方式。
去规划有的艺术生涯。
对 他能不能写到你的简历里。
对 我觉得可能就是。
有些人的有些项目。
如果你要继续当摄影师的话。
我劝你别放了
总之希望艺术家能多想想。
对
毕竟很多导演都拍过烂电影的。
其实也没关系
没关系
被批评没有什么？
是没什么所谓吗？
好的 那以上就是今天的全部内容。
我们下期再见
再见